As the Marvel Cinematic Universe grows bigger
by the year, the massive, widespread stories
and villains are becoming a bit harder to
follow.
So with all the time spent getting the big
picture in place, some confusing, hilarious,
or just plain awesome mistakes have managed
to slip into the finished movies.
We're willing to bet fans have missed plenty,
so here are 10 Editing Mistakes Marvel Movies
Hope You Missed.
Captain America: The First Avenger
He may be an American hero, but movie fans
in the Bahamas were just as excited to see
their own cameo in the movie - in the form
of the Bahamanian flag, flying between the
Stars and Stripes and the Union Jack at the
World Expo.
There's one problem: the flag wasn't created
until 1973.
Someone must have noticed, since it completely
disappears in the next shot.
The Avengers
In Hollywood, continuity isn't taken lightly,
with people specifically hired to keep sets,
costumes, and props exactly where they were
in the previous shots.
So when Cap takes a serious shot during the
final fight of The Avengers, his suit is destroyed,
and remains battle damaged into the next scenes.
But those who thought the damage added some
badass cred to Cap's bright costume don't
have long to enjoy it - the suit is back to
normal in the final scene, when it seems like
it probably should be there to show how hard
the battle really was.
Thor
When the god of thunder first realizes he
can no longer lift his famous hammer, he's
taken into custody by S.H.I.E.L.D. agents.
At least, in the story he is.
In the movie, the sound effects of metal handcuffs
can be heard clearly, but when the camera
switches to the overhead shot, not only is
it just a white band on his wrists, but so
loose, actor Chris Hemsworth's hands almost
slip out completely.
Ant-Man
Scott Lang's time as a superhero is almost
cut short when the movie's villain has a gun
to his head, but his trusty ants save the
day, jamming the gun's hammer to keep it from
firing.
Which would be a pretty cool moment, if the
entire scene leading up to it hadn't shown
they were using Glocks, without external hammers.
They didn't bother getting the actual gun
that would make sense, so were clearly hoping
viewers weren't paying close enough attention.
It isn't just CG ants who cause problems in
Ant-Man, but good old fashioned reflections,
too.
When Scott is parked in his van at night,
it's almost possible for the camera light
reflected on his chrome mirror to be mistaken
for a neon sign, but when the cameraman's
face comes completely into view as he pushes
in for a close-up, any chance at missing this
mistake is out the window.
Iron Man 3
No matter how incredible blockbuster air rescues
or freefalls might get, the actual math behind
them is almost always a problem.
Or, in the case of Iron Man 3, complete nonsense.
When Tony first sets out to rescue falling
Air Force One passengers, JARVIS lets him
know that they're at 18,000 feet and falling.
Just 10 seconds later, he claims they're at
10,000 feet.
And just 4 seconds later, they've fallen to
6,000.
A human at terminal velocity is close to 200
feet per second, but according to Jarvis,
they're falling at four times that, and accelerating.
Best to look, and not listen during this scene.
Thor: The Dark World
Some mistakes are down to human error, but
others are... more confusing.
When Thor and Loki are making their escape
from Asgard, the brave Fandral swings onto
an enemy ship to get the soldiers off their
back.
He first comes in from the left of screen,
before the shot is completely flipped.
There's no explanation meaning this is one
editing decision that simply doesn't make
sense.
Iron Man
Problems with science are nothing new for
Marvel, but if there's one thing that's nagged
the movies from the very start, it's the speed
of sound: the fact that a distant explosion
is always seen before it's heard, since sound
travels slower than light.
Those disappointed to see the Jericho missile
in Iron Man detonate a split second AFTER
they heard it have hopefully gotten used to
it.
Since Thor's hammer still rattles ear drums
when it launches a sonic boom, no matter how
far away it really is.
Somewhere at Marvel, there's a science buff
tearing their hair out.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
Most fans are willing to forget that it wouldn't
really be possible for Arnim Zola to live
on as an artificial intelligence thanks to
a sea of magnetic tape, since the scene it
makes possible is a pretty important one.
The footage from the first Captain America
that he shows to Steve and Natasha is just
as much of a leap, but we have to draw the
line at being able to broadcast black and
white film reels and HD newspaper scans on
the green-and-black monochrome monitors actually
found in the base.
The computer monitors might annoy techies
in the audience, but for those who rely on
maps or GPS, The Winter Soldier is even worse.
When the coordinates are shown for the satellite
launch ship in the Indian Ocean, both latitude
and longitude are given in degrees NORTH,
when latitude should be given in East or West.
It's a weird mistake, since the numbers actually
make sense, just not the directions, and it's
made again when we see the SHIELD Triskellion,
with both coordinates given in NORTH and SOUTH.
Those are just some of the editing mistakes
that seemed to have slipped by the great minds
at Marvel Studios.
Are there any we missed?
What other editing mistakes have you noticed?
Sound off in the comments and don’t forget
to subscribe to our channel for more great
videos like this one!